el desplazamiento forzado es un drama al
que muchos tienen que hacer frente y
asia por conflictos armados o
persecución política actualmente al
menos 82 como 4 millones de personas en
todo el mundo se han visto obligadas a
huir de sus hogares en el caso de los
refugiados fuera de las fronteras de sus
países y en el de los desplazados dentro
de la misma nación en busca de una mejor
vida en otros territorios
muchos se han topado con otra realidad
vivir en campos de refugiados o
comunidades separadas como única opción
un problema que afecta especialmente a
países como siria golpeada por una
guerra que los expertos gastan como la
peor crisis humanitaria de los últimos
tiempos o venezuela donde se vive una
profunda crisis económica repartidos por
el mundo la mayoría de los refugiados
intentan llegar a naciones vecinas
aunque la carga de acogida es
tremendamente desigual en 2020 los
países más desarrollados tan solo dieron
acogida al 19% de los refugiados
mientras que las naciones en desarrollo
tuvieron que alojar al 27 por ciento de
la población
a gran parte de los 67 millones de
sirios en condición de refugiados están
en países como turquía o alemania y en
el caso de los venezolanos el destino
más común es colombia territorio
fronterizo la crisis de migrantes y
refugiados se extiende también por zonas
como el mediterráneo a diferencia de los
refugiados los migrantes no abandonan
sus países por peligro de muerte sino
que buscan mejorar su calidad de vida un
matiz a veces difícil de distinguir por
otro lado acnur advierte que el 42 por
ciento de los refugiados tienen menos de
18 años muchos sufren abusos un problema
humanitario que desde naciones unidas-
insisten se debe solucionar con la
colaboración de todos los países
desarrollados del mundo